even though the diets widely vary you
know in terms of low carb high fat
um you know high carb low fat different
plants and herbs and spices being used
in those regions different forms of
alcohol intake etc what we do see in
terms of prevailing characteristics in
all those regions is a
there's always some semblance of fasting
worked in a lot of times it's based on
on religious concepts you know like the
mediterranean diet you know it's very
popular among
like eastern orthodox christians and
then there's a ton of of special fasts
in that diet certain days where you
don't eat red meat
certain periods of time where you're
avoiding a high intake of proteins
certain periods of time where you're
just straight up fasting
we see fasting is one predominant
characteristic of every single healthy
diet on the face of the planet some type
of fasting
and some type of time during the day or
the week or the month where you're not
eating a lot of protein
talk about the diet stuff so because i
think a lot of people
especially in the last year and a half
they've realized that they got to take
control
of their health and their lives you know
trapped at home you can't go to the gym
you're eating take out food everything's
being delivered et cetera et cetera
what's like some basic dietary stuff
that that people should know well
you know the the fact is that based on
biochemical individuality you know
different shapes of the stomach the
pancreas the liver
different vitamin d excretion rates and
different ways that we all process food
as unique human beings
paired with the fact that we all have
unique genetics right like
someone from let's say sub-saharan
africa is going to do
far better based on equatorial location
and sun exposure to
high carb intake and lots of fruits
and um and a lower amount of like
saturated fats compared to someone of
northern european descent who does
really good on like
fish steak fermented foods you know high
fat milk stuff like that
um you know the idea is that it's not
going to be the same for everybody
but we live in an era in which the you
know the same type of self
quantification test that would have cost
like tens of thousands of dollars that
say like you know the princeton
longevity institute or duke or
you know any of these places where you
know a lot of execs would normally get
tested
to really really dial in something like
diet or nutrition or supplementation
those are available to us in the comfort
of our own home now for you know for for
a fraction of the cost so people can
test their blood
they can test their genetics they can
test their stool for like
you know what what the gut is asking for
and and
by testing your body by looking at your
genetics
and by paying attention to your own
unique biochemical individuality
you should be able to tweak your diet to
you and what i mean by that is like you
know the same
ketogenic diet that your neighbor used
to lose 20 pounds
might be super crappy for you and cause
inflammation and weight gain in you
because you have a liver and gallbladder
that isn't processing that high intake
of saturated fats very well
or you have let's say like an apple e4
e4 gene which would dictate that high
intake of fats predisposes you to
alzheimer's
or dementia or you have poor enzyme
production that dictates that you can't
burn fats that well because you don't
have enough lipase
and so that's just one example of the
fact that
there is no one diet that works well for
everyone now that being said
a couple of things to think about first
of all when you look at epidemiological
data
for a wide wide variety of the world's
populations probably because
humans likely originated somewhere in
the fertile crescent
something along the lines of like a
low-carb ish mediterranean diet
tends to work really well for a lot of
people you know not like an olive garden
unlimited breadsticks
diet but i mean like a diet very rich in
herbs and
spices and you know a wide variety of
plant matter
some amounts of fish and eggs red meat
but in moderation
lots of healthy omega-3 fatty acids not
only from those fish but things like
extra virgin olive oil and avocados and
avocado oil and seeds and nuts like
that low-carb mediterranean profile
tends to be something
that seems to agree with a lot of people
and then when you look at
you know these blue zones you know these
longevity hot spots around the world
like
you know nikoia and acaria and sardinia
and
loma linda even though the diets widely
vary
you know in terms of low carb high fat
um you know high carb
low fat different plants and herbs and
spices being used in those regions
different forms of
alcohol intake etc what we do see in
terms of prevailing characteristics in
all those regions is a
there's always some semblance of fasting
worked in a lot of times it's based on
on religious concepts you know like the
mediterranean diet you know it's very
popular among
like eastern orthodox christians and
then there's a ton of of special fasts
in that diet certain days where you
don't eat red meat
certain periods of time where you're
avoiding a high intake of proteins
certain periods of time where you're
just straight up fasting we see fasting
is one predominant characteristic of
every single healthy diet on the face of
the planet some type of fasting
and some type of time during the day or
the week or the month where you're not
eating a lot of protein
because protein in high amounts can tend
to have a little bit of an accelerated
aging effect
we also see the concept of eating with
people right
um not only saying grace or having a
moment of silence or having a moment of
appreciation
or sacredness around a meal but also not
stuffing your face
with a superfood smoothie while you're
you know going 65 miles an hour down the
highway on your way to work instead
and i'm highly cognizant of this myself
if i'm gonna eat i always eat in what's
called a parasympathetic state
i i sit down i do a little you know just
a few centering breasts like in through
the nose
out through the mouth i say grace i chew
each bite 25 to
40 times i try to eat with people so i'm
not distracted by my computer by my
phone but instead i'm visiting with
people and we see
that as another predominant
characteristic of a healthy diet like
eating in a very low stress state
and eating with people and then you also
see
a wide intake of a huge variety of
plants and herbs and spices and i
realized that diets like the
paleo diet or the carnivore diet a lot
of these highly restrictive
diets have popped up and become very
popular over the years
and a big premise of those diets is that
they eliminate
a lot of built-in plant defense
mechanisms like plants can't move and so
because they don't have hooves and teeth
and claws they develop things like
you know gluten and lectins and other
things that would cause a mammal's gut
to be a little bit disturbed cause that
mammal to
poop out the seeds of that plant
elsewhere so that plant can flourish or
cause that mammal
not to come back to that plant to eat it
again because it kind of hurt
and so if you have a compromised gut or
if you have the inability
to be able to do like our ancestors
would have done and soak and sprout and
ferment and properly prepare a lot of
your plant matter
then yeah doing something like a paleo
or carnivore diet
has efficacy um however
in people with healthy guts who don't
have a lot of health issues like a wide
variety of plants and herbs and spices
really seems to induce longevity and be
a healthier form of a diet and that's
another thing
we see in a lot of these blue zones
they're not highly restrictive they ate
a huge variety
like 100 plus different plants and herbs
and spices whereas you know in america
we often
i think we're somewhere around like 15
to 20. right so
would you say that paleo and carnivore
that kind of stuff like it's sort of
short term to help fix the gut
inflammation kind of stuff but not
necessarily long-term
yeah let's say you have leaky gut you
have inflammation
issues you need to kind of give your gut
a break or you need to not have a lot of
gluten a lot of lectins a lot of dairy
you know follow a carnivore diet or a
paleo diet for like 12 to 16 weeks
to allow your gut to heal and
re-stabilize but then
begin to re-incorporate you know things
like whatever you know kale and
cucumbers and tomatoes and you know all
those
foods that you might have been missing
out on and then probably the
the final big big thing that we see in a
lot of these healthy locations
is not the absence of sugar right we
actually see a lot of these
like they like their chocolates they
like their sweets um they like their
candies you look at
you know the analysis of you know
centenarians or people you know many
kids who lived 115 plus years old i was
writing a fantastic article the other
day about like 20 different 115 year old
people
and a lot of them you know they comment
oh i love to have my chocolate every day
i love
my love my sweets and you know there's
even some of them that you know that
that would like smoke a cigarette a day
and yeah but the one thing that you'll
notice
in these folks and also in a lot of
these longevity hot spots
is almost complete absence of vegetable
oil intake right canola oil
safflower oil sunflower oil a lot of
these vegetable oils
that we tend to see especially in in
processed and packaged foods
or used in restaurants to cook and the
reason for that is because
vegetable oils based on the fact that
they're comprised of fats
are what your body uses to create things
like cell membranes cholesterol
mitochondrial membranes your body uses
these oils as building blocks
and if there are unstable oils rancid
oils
oils that have been exposed to high
amounts of heat or pressure
what happens is those vegetable oils
really truly become a case of you
are what you eat and they create rampant
inflammation weak cell membranes
you know poor metabolism and so whereas
sugar isn't as big of a deal as most
people think
vegetable oils i tell people you want to
be healthy ruthlessly eliminate
vegetable oils from your diet and
sometimes that means
you know like me if i go to a restaurant
i literally ask them like i'm that
[ __ ] who says like what
what'd you cook the brussels sprouts in
or can i have my
my salad but bring the dressing on the
side and then like you know i have like
a little fanny pack i go out with and i
just have like a four ounce thing of
olive oil in there right and i'll put
olive oil on my salad instead of
whatever
sauce or dressing they have at the
restaurant because i am so aware
of vegetable oil intake that's the one
you want everything everything basically
to be cooked either in olive anything
that needs to be cooked with oil
to be cooked with either olive oil or
avocado oil does it matter which one
you know the top one the top ones i like
are butter ghee
extra virgin olive oil avocado oil
macadamia nut oil or any super stable
animal fat like tallow
or suet or any of those fats you know
coconut oil another one like the fats
that are solid at room temperature
but not solid at room temperature
because like crisco they've been
synthesized
but instead solid because that's the way
they naturally are so
so yeah so when it comes to diet you
know just coming full circle here
um you know eat in a de-stress state
have some periods of fasting and protein
restriction
be careful with sugar but you don't got
to swear that off completely completely
eliminate vegetable oil
and eat a wide variety of plants and
herbs and spices and if you can
get your genetics tested you get your
blood tested just kind of see what your
ancestors ate
see what your bio chemically kind of
like prime to actually be able to
flourish with
and that way you can take some of those
concepts i just outlined
and then tweak your diet a little bit so
it's more customized to you
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
lifestyles instead of non-stop yelling
check out our lifestyle playlist and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell